[Music]
Americans spend an average of $1,100 per
person per year on prescription drugs
that's more than anyone else in the
world it's true Americans take a lot of
pills but the real difference for the
u.s. is the price of those drugs which
many warn are rapidly becoming
unaffordable President Donald Trump has
promised to bring drug prices down by
forcing drug makers to bid for the
government's business Pharma has a lot
of lobbies a lot of lobbyists and a lot
of power and there's very little bidding
on drugs here's the situation the
pharmaceutical industry has come under
fire for what critics have labeled price
gouging everybody is doing it it in
capitalism you try to get the highest
price for that you can't for a product
Martin shkreli it became the poster
child of greed when his company raised
the price of an old anti-parasitic drug
from 13 dollars to 750 dollars a pill
and in 2016
Milan pharmaceuticals CEO Heather brash
was grilled by Congress when her company
raised the price of an EpiPen more than
twofold since 2012 so how do drug prices
work in the US versus the rest of the
world in Europe governments negotiate
directly with drug makers to limit what
their state-funded health systems pay in
the u.s. drug company is more or less
set whatever price the market will bear
most of the costs are paid for either by
Medicare the government program for the
elderly or by private insurance while
Medicare legally can't negotiate drug
prices private insurers can private
payers typically rely on third party
pharmacy benefit managers or PPM's
like Express Scripts and CVS Caremark to
negotiate discounts PBMs often make
exclusive and secretive deals with drug
makers which can result in an insurance
company covering some drugs but not
others in the end Americans wind up
paying about 17 percent of drug costs
out of pocket so here's the argument
pharmaceutical companies say that high
profits are necessary to fund research
and development and that regulating drug
prices might slow medical advances
advocates of regulation say lower prices
wouldn't stop innovation and point out
that some drug companies spend more on
marketing than they do on R&D